This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode.
Today, we are talking about a ride of passage for so many of us, but also one of the scariest things you can do in your 20s, moving to a new city, whether it's after you graduate college or for college or just for fun, for work, for a relationship, leaving what we know and the place we call home can be, honestly, it's romantic, it's exciting, it's also deeply conflicting, right?
There is the allure of a fresh start and then there is also a deep fear. Fear around, like, am I even going to like this? Am I going to make friends? I'm going to be able to afford it? Am I going to find the places and the routines and the community that I love? I have moved around a lot in my life, but especially in my 20s. I'm on my third city of my 20s so far. And you guys know I've just moved internationally for the first time.
I now call London Home. And I think all the experiences that I've had before have actually given me a bit of a routine and a formula that I am currently following to adjust to this new city and to make this place feel like home. And so I want to share that with you all. I will say it isn't without its challenges. I don't want to romanticize it too much because part of the reality and I guess the price you pay for a new beginning is that it's going to be hard and you are going to be sad and there will be lonely times. I won't lie. London has, London's kind of knocked me on my butt. I've been pretty lonely.
I haven't really found my groove yet. I miss my dog. I miss my dog. It feels like I'm literally grieving somebody. But having a plan is sometimes all you kind of need to break out of that funk and just let you enjoy the process a little bit more. Because that's what a little bit. is it's a process it's going to get better we'll also of course touch on the psychology and the science to why these tips for adjusting to a new city work and what the research tells us to do but without further ado let's get into my five best tips for moving to a new city in your 20s moving to a new city is again always going to be difficult for literally everyone it does not discriminate for a few obvious reasons, for a few non-obvious ones as well that I want to go through and I want to touch on.
Number one, the reason it's going to be hard is because it's a complete upheaval to your routine, your sense of stability, and what is comfortable for you. We are psychologically grounded by what we know and by having a stable environment and having that stable environment directly links to emotional stability, even physical health at times as well when you first move to a new city. It could literally be the city over, it could be an hour away. But there is always going to be a lack of familiarity that feels stressful and uncomfortable at times at least for a few months.
You're constantly encountering new stimuli and new things and new streets and new systems and smells and your brain has to be more active in dissecting and processing these things. compared to the status quo of your previous home city. This whole process taxes your cognitive resources more than usual. And you may not immediately notice how much this strains and overwhelms you, but it will. It's inevitable. And it's going to lead to exhaustion and a lot of emotion.
That's what makes this adjustment period pretty difficult. Often how this manifests is, obviously, through homesickness. Home sickness is like heartbreak in a lot of ways. It's like a longing for what we used to know and what felt easy and safe, even if it wasn't what was best for us. Yes, where we used to live isn't a person. I know that, but it's, you have an attachment to it, like it is a relationship. You have memories, you have feelings, you have traditions with your old city and moving away from it is an unacknowledged grief that things are never going to be the same. Like, it's never going to be what it was and that's grief, that's sadness. The second reason moving to a new city is bound
to be difficult is that you typically have fewer social connections. I know, call me misobvious, but it impacts you on a level beyond what you think it does. Some of you may be really lucky, maybe the lucky ones and you've moved to be closer to your friends. I'm deeply jealous of you. but that's also not, that's not the norm. Typically, we are starting from scratch, and that is so isolating, even when, you know, you call your friends every day, even when they come and visit,
sometimes you just want a friend, you can go out for a beer with once a week. Sometimes you just want physical connections, somebody you can sit across from at a table and just vent to, and they're just there for you and there, and you could reach out and touch them. I remember when I first moved to Sydney, I knew so few people and I was trying so hard, desperately
hard to meet people. I was doing all the things. I was rock climbing. I was life drawing, et cetera, et cetera. None of it was working. And I just called my dad and I was like, all I want is a friend. One single friend. That's all I want.
That would make this easier. It goes without saying not having that support system. It lowers our coping in so many ways. somewhat similar to this and the third reason it's so difficult, the one I hear so few people actually talk about is moving for a period of time is going to mean that you don't know who you are. It's just natural. It will always force an identity reset whether you want it to or not. When you move to a new city, you don't just lose places and people like you lose mirrors, the people who knew your history and your patterns and your inside jokes and the roles or the
archetypes you played. In your old city, you didn't have to explain who you were. Like, your identity was socially reinforced constantly. In a new place, no one knows your backstory. You're suddenly untethered from the version of yourself that was consistently reflected back to you. psychologically this is destabilizing because our sense of self is not just formed in isolation, it's relational, it's formed in our relationships to other people. Research on self-concept clarity shows that when external feedback and social continuity disappear, we experience more anxiety, more doubt, and more emotional volatility. You're starting from scratch in, like, in more ways than one.
So how long is that going to last? That is what a lot of us probably want to know. Like, skip to the good part. When's it going to get better for me? I spoke about this in my I moved to London episode. But I believe it takes six months to adjust to a new city. Six months before you know if it was the right decision or if it was the wrong one. No major feelings you have before six months can be trusted. You can't decide like, I'm going to be. I'm, going to apply for citizenship and I'm going to move here permanently, but you equally cannot decide this was the worst call I've ever made and I need to go home now. Even if you feel either of those things really strongly and really deeply, your emotions before the six month mark cannot be trusted. The consensus is in some psychological communities, you know, it takes 90 days to form a habit. It's a bit
oversimplified when you look at that research. But let's say 90 days. Let's say three months, three months to get used to a routine, to get used to a habit, the habit of a new city, the new systems, the new customs. And then I think it takes another three months to really decide like that routine. You've gotten used to it. Do you enjoy it? At six months, you will be so surprised. You will wake up one day and things might not be perfect, but you will notice a shift. You've made some friends, you can navigate transport easier, you have a bit of a weekend routine, markets, shops, walk, trivia, that starts to feel normal. At this point, your allostatic load as well is also going to lower, like we spoke about before.
Moving to a new city is a major life event. It's going to temporarily increase cortisol. It's also going to be triggering your sympathetic nervous system. You're going to be very, very stressed. when you get into the routines, predictability naturally lowers some of those responses. With that in mind, let's get into some of the tips that can help you make that transition a little bit smoother before the six-month mark and after the six-month mark as well. Starting with my most important tip of all, do not go home for the first three months if you can
avoid it. The worst thing I did when I moved to Sydney was that I kept going back to. to Canberra. And the worst thing I did when I moved to Canberra was that I kept going back to Melbourne, like every weekend. And I get it, like, I have sympathy for that version of me. I was so lonely. I miss my friends. I miss what I knew. But it meant that in hindsight, it took me longer to adjust because I wasn't investing and I didn't have the free time on the weekends that I needed to make a real investment in my new city. Consider it, like how I can consider it now is like going no contact with an ex. You can't, you know, expect to adjust to being
single or being in a new city if you are constantly reminded of what you had before and all the good feelings towards that place. Like all those good feelings keep getting activated the more you've returned, meaning that the positive association doesn't reduce to reference the psychology here adjustment to something new relies on habituation and also extinction learning if you want to adjust to not having something or to a new habit or a new routine. You have this learned response to your old city, right? One of positive feelings, one of joy, friendship, relief when returning. That means your new city at this time is never going to be able to compete with that the more you continue to reinforce that feeling. The only way you can extinguish that association and make room for this
new city to feel as comfortable as your old one is to stop that feeling of like this place I used to live is the only place I'm going to feel good in by constantly going back. You are not giving yourself the best chance here if you just keep returning every weekend. This is like classic negative reinforcement as well. The discomfort you are. are experiencing in the new city is being reduced by going home to the old city, which basically strengthens the urge to escape again next weekend, which means you form a habit of avoidance towards your new city, meaning you and the new city never get to form your own relationship. The same way that when you break up with an ex, like you and yourself, and you feeling okay
being single never gets to happen if you keep going back to them. I know it feels strange to hear me talking about cities as if they were people. and as if they are relationships. But I think when we frame it in this way, like it makes a little bit more sense and we understand the, we understand the emotional implications better. If you want to feel like your new city is the new normal and is good for you, go no contact with your old city. Tip number two, for the first three months at least, never spend a Friday night at home.
this is probably my most controversial one. I know some people, that's the day they really recharge. And especially for my introverted listeners, like, I'm sorry. I know you're going to hate me for saying this. But part of what makes a new place feel like home is, of course, the relationships you build there and the fun memories you make on your weekends or on your nights off. When we are experiencing a lot of stress and a lot of overwhelm and a lot of anxiety from all this newness, it's very easy to withdraw and to want to recharge by yourself and you want to watch the office
for the 15th time and you want to cook your comfort meal and you want to cuddle up in bed. At that moment, you have to ignore that instinct and you have to do the hard thing. You've got to go out and meet new people. You have to go and make some plans. You've got to go to a social meet up, a board game night, get into some kind of pottery Pilates painting class. You're going to go drinking with your colleagues. You can rest on Thursday night. You can rest on Saturday night.
But Friday nights, as a practice, at least for the first three, six months, are going to be your social nights. And unless you are sick or unless you are dying, you are going to be somewhere that is not home. I think having that one day where you make this a priority is super important because it gets us into the practice of being. social and meeting new people when the path of least resistance, especially in the early days would be to do nothing and to spend that time alone. A bonus tip for you as well that I think falls under this
is don't be afraid to get desperate and to do things you otherwise wouldn't for friendship. Don't be afraid to come on too strong and to message the same person a few times in a row to ask what their plans are or to reach out to people that you don't really know that well slash at all to do something or to go to, I don't know, an event or a meetup that you would normally maybe avoid. Friendship meetups, concerts alone, dinner by yourself, like drinks with mutual, mutual, mutual,
friends, like, feels awkward. Chances are if somebody else is there, they're feeling the same way. they are in a similar position to be in that situation. For example, somebody who is doing this very well is my boyfriend right now. Like, he has, I told him this tip and he has taken it to like a new level. He's like Thursday, Friday, Saturday, goodbye, you will not be seeing me. Like, last night, he went to a sketch night for three hours with a bunch of strangers. I've never seen him draw in his life.
I didn't see the picture. I don't know what he drew. He didn't bring it home for me. So maybe he didn't go. He definitely did. Like another night as well, he went to a board game night. I think like on Saturday. And like this is the same guy who, to give you some context, like when we were in Sydney,
typical night for him is he would work really late, get home at 7, go to the gym, play video games with his buddies. Probably like Monday to Friday and Sunday he would do that. And then maybe like Friday and Saturday would go and do something social. So this is not his norm. but you've got to make the most. And what I respect about what he's doing right now is like he's making the most of the momentum and the motivation that the first few months and the desperation of the first few months is going to give you. Also, another bonus tip, sorry, bonus tip like 2.3.
Lower your social expectations at first. You're not aiming for the perfect friendship group. You are aiming for at least the beginning. one friend. In the next three months, one friend, just one person that you click with, that you like, that you could see yourself getting to know, then move from there.
Don't immediately feel like if you don't have the big group of friends, you know, you're never going to have that. When I moved to Sydney, it took me three years in Sydney to get anything close to a friendship group that felt cohesive and whole. It did come.
It just took me a little while longer. The way I got there as well was I just focused on that one friend, that two friend, those individual relationships first, and then I moved from there. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but when we return, I have three more tips for you, plus a bonus one. I actually think most people overlook when they first move to a new city, so stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
There's two golden rules. that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the tape.
right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
Kyr Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're a good person because you're a free because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two
different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person join me care gains is we have real conversations about healing growth fatherhood pressure and purpose on my new podcast learn the hard way open your free iHeartRadio app search learn the hard way and listen
now we're up to tip number three tip number three make a bucket list for your new city and start ticking one thing off that bucket list per week even and especially if it means that you have to go alone. This time is going to be tough. We've already talked about that. We've already covered that. We're done with that. But it will be easier if you romanticize it a little bit more and you kind of treat it like
you're just a long-term tourist, at least at first. Yesterday I ticked off an item from my bucket list. I went to the British Library and I wrote my scripts there. and it was great. I got out of my house. I saw some original like Sylvia Plath letters. Someone did try to steal my seat whilst I was in the bathroom, but you know, I saw new things, I had fun, it was snowing. Why I have found this helpful is because firstly, yes, it keeps you focusing on all the amazing parts of this new city that you are yet to see, even on the days it's hard, keeps you focused on the privilege of this experience. It also has kept me occupied during, times when I do feel lonely.
You know, yes, it's not ideal. Doing things alone when you feel lonely, you might think it makes it worse. But going where the people are and going where there is newness and novelty and things that you're actually excited to see and you would be excited to see if you are only here for a week makes it so much better and just reminds me
like there is so much to explore here and there is so much to like get out and see even if I'm doing it alone to begin with. It also creates what we call place attachment. Places don't feel meaningful because of time alone or even because of relationships alone. They feel meaningful because of memories. The memories we create through effort. And this is one way of doing it.
Having that adventurer mindset, I think also additionally helps you find cool stuff and cool places that feel like your own and also make you feel like a local. I feel like you know the local secret. because you're wondering, you're walking, you are doing stuff, you are appreciating, again, the privilege of this experience. And honestly, I think there is also a big dopamine element here. Having this bucket list gives your brain something to look forward to. And that sense of forward motion is protective during transitions. It combats the emotional flatness that often comes with loneliness and adjustment. because you're generating regular experiences and moments for yourself of reward and accomplishment
and dopamine and novelty. Make your bucket list. I will say I still have things on my Sydney and my Canberra bucket list that I didn't do and I regret that. So I'm fully committed to my London one and to pursuing that like novelty and all the fun things that this city has for me. We're actually going to do a full 180 here for tip number four. Bucketless, novelty, important, amazing.
So are your routines. You need to establish a routine that you are consistent and loyal to. You guys know me. I am honestly, I'm such a routine hater. I love just like waking up and being like, what's on the agenda for the day and like making it up as I go along? That's how my brain operates. I don't love the structure.
when I move to a new city, I get invested. I get serious about my routine because I know this is the key, the psychological key, the routine key that unlock so many other doors for me in this new environment. Pick, for example, one or two community spaces and go as much as possible. Repetition is your best friend here. Going to the same coffee shop, the same local grocery store, the same gym classes, potter. classes, morning walk, every day, doing those things is how you are going to build community, your community, simply through convenience and exposure. And I know it works. I know this works because I've done it before. When you stay loyal to your routine and your local favorites and your environment favorites, I get location favorites, I should say, you find other people who will do the same and who are already operating on a similar cycle as you, and through simple exposure, you gain closeness. These people may not necessarily become your best friends, but they will become your community. And the value of these low effort daily conversations
with familiar people, the girl in your boxing class, the barista, the man selling the big issue is crucial. These are crucial, even if they're not the most important, because it makes us feel less invisible, especially in big cities where you sometimes feel like, you know, would anybody even notice if I'm missing? This is a nice way to not feel so terrifying, terrifyingly small. On top of that, one further psychological bonus is that this mere exposure effect also does actually help us love the city more, not just the people we encounter, but the city in general. One of the most robust findings in social psychology is that we like people and places more simply because we encounter them repeatedly. Frequency for adjustment matters. That's why your old town,
your old home, your old city felt special. You just spent a lot of time there and you built up your routine and people without perhaps even realizing it. So investing in that now in your new city is going to pay just mass dividends in the future. I think we're now up to like, I think we're up to tip number five. So we're going to move into some more like very specific practical territory. This is something I'm really glad I've done in the past and I continue to do a super practical tip to kind of break things up.
Do not sign a lease. If you have just moved to a new city, do not sign a lease straight away. and do not sign a lease before you move and you see the place. Get an Airbnb. This tip is so important to me. Get an Airbnb or sublet. Stay with friends.
Stay with friends of friends for at least the first couple to few weeks if you can. Here is my justification for this, especially in big cities. Where you live really matters. And not just whether the neighborhood is safe or you like the apartment or people, are friendly, but whether it's close enough to work, how long your commute's going to be, whether it contains people your similar age, whether it's got the amenities you like, the vibes you like, the green spaces you like. There is this panicked instinct we have, and I've certainly had it before, to kind of lock down a place like straight away, because we don't, obviously, we want a
roof over our head. But I really recommend exploring a few neighborhoods and streets and places before you pay all that money for potentially a location you don't like or that it's going to give you a two-hour commute or doesn't suit your needs. I've actually had this happen with a few friends. Just recently they moved overseas in the past few months. My friends, Matt and his wife, Sophia, they moved to Canada and they took over someone's lease before they got there because they were so stressed about finding a place. And like they are almost an hour and a half from where they were. and from where all their friends live and from live music venues and the cinemas and the bars that they like. And they're stuck in that 12-month contract now.
有一个遮风挡雨的地方。但我真的建议大家在付清昂贵的房租、搬到一个可能并不喜欢、通勤时间长达两小时或无法满足需求的地方之前，先去探索几个街区、街道和地方。我的一些朋友就经历过这种情况。就在最近几个月，他们搬到了海外。我的朋友马特和他的妻子索菲亚，他们搬到了加拿大，在到达之前就接手了别人的租约，因为他们太焦虑找不到住处了。结果他们离原来的地方、离所有朋友住的地方、离他们喜欢的现场音乐场所、电影院和酒吧远了将近一个半小时。现在他们被困在那份12个月的合同里了。
And I don't blame them. Like, I think they really wanted the security of it. But it's worth the extra money and the reduction in security to really explore before you commit when you first move. Because rent is freaking expensive. And leases are hard to bring. break. Having that two week, three week buffer, I think of it as insurance. It's insurance for the choice you make on the location you live. We did two weeks at an Airbnb in Camden when we first moved to London and like huge shout out to our Airbnb hosts. I don't think they're listening
我并不怪他们。我觉得他们真的很想要那种安全感。但在刚搬到一个新地方时，在做出承诺之前花点额外的时间去探索，牺牲一点安全感，绝对是物超所值的。因为房租太贵了，而且租约很难打破。留出两周到三周的缓冲期，我认为这就像是一份保险。这是为你所选择的居住地点买的一份保险。我们刚搬到伦敦时，在卡姆登的一家爱彼迎住了两周，非常感谢我们的房东。我想他们可能没在听
but because I don't think I'm, they're not my target demographic. But they were so kind. They were like these guys in their like 40s or 50s and they were so welcoming and they gave us so many recommendations and they like we really locked in on seeing as many neighborhoods as possible because we did that. I was so convinced actually to give my own story on this. I was so convinced when we moved to London stupidly. I was like, I want to move to Notting Hill. I know. Probably because I saw the movie but also because I have friends who live there and I was like, Notting Hill is trendy. I want to I want to live in Notting Hill. And then we went and saw a few places there and I was like,
因为我觉得我不是他们的目标受众。但他们太善良了。他们是一对四五十岁的夫妇，非常热情，给了我们很多建议，让我们能够尽可能多地去了解各个街区。正因为我们这样做了，我当时非常坚决——说实话，讲讲我自己的故事——我们刚搬到伦敦时，我傻乎乎地坚信，我一定要住在诺丁山。我懂的。可能因为我看过那部电影，也因为我有朋友住在那里，当时我觉得诺丁山很时髦，我就是想住在诺丁山。然后我们去那里看了一些房子，结果发现，
I do not want to live here. This is actually not that great. It's a bit far from everything else. And it's a bit posh, not posh enough for Notting Hill. And that was a great decision. And I would have chosen Notting Hill if we didn't have that buffer. And I would have never felt comfortable living my house in exercise gear or without a full face of makeup. So I'm so glad we did that.
我根本不想住在这里。其实这里并没有那么好。离其他地方有点远。而且有点高档，又不够真正的诺丁山那种高档。这是一个非常棒的决定。如果我们没有那段缓冲期，我最终肯定会选择诺丁山。而且我绝对不会有勇气穿着运动服或者素颜就敢走出家门。所以我太庆幸我们当时那样做了。
before we wrap up, I have two smaller bonus tips for you guys for before I go. You guys know me. I've got to do my extra credit work for you guys. I've got to give you something a little bit extra. Bonus tip number one. Actually, I think by this stage it's like bonus tip number four. I forgot about the ones before. But bonus tip number one, when you move to a new city,
在结束之前，我还给大家准备了两个小小的额外建议。大家也了解我，我总是喜欢给你们做点附加题，给你们一些额外的东西。额外建议一。事实上，我觉得到这个阶段这应该算是额外建议四了，我把前面的都忘了。不过，额外建议一，当你搬到一个新城市时，
I actually think it's really important to invest in making your home or your room nice and cozy, even if it costs that little bit extra. And I'm going to explain why. Moving countries, yeah, it's expensive. Visas alone are like a tenth of people's like yearly incomes. But if there is one thing, you're going to spend money on when you get there, making the place you live feel comfortable and feel homely is it as we've been like buying furniture and decorating and doing all that stuff at our new place i keep definitely feeling this sense of like why am i spending money on this why did i buy a rug like why am i why did i buy a lamp why did i buy a nice couch like that's silly we're just going to sell it we're not going to be here for that long and the answer is like it does
我真的觉得投资让你的家或房间变得温馨舒适非常重要，哪怕这需要多花一点钱。我来解释一下原因。跨国搬迁确实很贵，光是签证费就占了很多人年收入的十分之一。但如果你到了那里之后要在某个地方花钱，那就是让你的居住地感觉舒适、有家的感觉。在我们买家具、搞装修、在新家里忙活这些事的时候，我心里一直有一种声音在嘀咕：我为什么要花这个钱？我为什么要买地毯？为什么要买台灯？为什么要买个漂亮的沙发？这太蠢了，我们以后又得卖掉，又不会在这里住太久。而答案是——这确实
feel like it helps it feels like if i'm going to live here and really give it something if i don't feel comfortable I'm going to be gone in six months because I'm going to hate it. I need to feel like my space is safe and comfortable and has my personality involved in it so that I have somewhere to retreat to when things get hard. Otherwise, I'm going to burn out pretty quick and I'm going to feel pretty, you know, disheartened. If you really want to give your city a crack, you can do all the things, but you've got to be invested as well. And you have to make it mentally easier on yourself by making it comfortable. The three things I would actually say to spend money on.
很有帮助。感觉如果我要住在这里并真正去体验生活，如果我感到不舒服，我可能六个月后就会走人，因为我会讨厌这里的。我需要让我的空间感到安全、舒适，并且融入我的个性，这样当事情变得艰难时，我才有一个可以退守的地方。否则，我很快就会精疲力竭，也会感到非常沮丧。如果你真的想好好体验这座城市，你可以尝试各种事情，但你自身也必须投入。你需要通过让生活变得舒适，来减轻心理上的负担。如果要说我建议花钱买的三样东西，
If you are going to spend money when you move to a new city, nice bed sheets and nice towels, a nice lamp or a nice light source, and then a nice picture frame or some nice pictures or some nice art. It does make a big difference. Our final tip of this episode, probably our most important, don't try so hard to recreate your old life
如果你搬到一个新城市打算花点钱的话，那就是：好的床单和毛巾、一盏好看的台灯或优质的光源，然后是一个漂亮的相框、一些好看的照片或精美的艺术品。这确实会有很大的不同。我们这一集的最后一条建议，可能也是最重要的一条：不要费尽心机去重建你以前的生活，
in a new place. No matter how hard you try, it's just never going to be the same. And it's just going to make you more miserable. If there was ever a time to try new things, to reinvent yourself, to force yourself to build different habits, routines, enjoy different things. This is your time.
在一个全新的地方。无论你多么努力，一切都永远不会和以前一样。那只会让你更加痛苦。如果说有什么时候是应该尝试新鲜事物、重塑自我、强迫自己建立不同的习惯和日常、享受不同的体验的话，现在就是最好的时机。
Like right now, you have a blank slate to be an entirely new person. If you want to be so, if you want to do so, so many people never get that opportunity. And they remain the same version. versions of themselves for their whole lives because they feel caged in by geography and the people they know and their hometown or their home city. This is going to be hard. It's also going to be a freaking great adventure. And I want you to lean in as much as possible to the fresh start and the new beginnings and how you're going to make this different, the person you want to be. And I think it will,
就像现在，你拥有一张白纸，可以成为一个全新的人。如果你想的话。很多人永远没有这样的机会，他们一辈子都保持着同一个版本的自我，因为他们被地理位置、认识的人、家乡或原本的城市所禁锢。这过程会很艰难，但也将是一场无与伦比的伟大冒险。我希望你们尽可能地去拥抱这个全新的起点、新的开始，去思考你将如何让这一切变得不同，去成为你想成为的那种人。而且我相信，
I think all of that, that whole mentality of like, cool, this is going to be tough but I'm going to make the most of it. I'm going to reinvent myself, whatever it is. It makes you feel a little bit more positive and unoptimistic about the future when the hard stuff does come up. Thank you so much for listening. I'm so excited for you if you've just moved or if you are in the process of thinking about moving, even if you're six months down the line, like it's going to get great. It's going to be amazing. It's going to get better. If you have made it to the end of this episode, welcome. Thank you so much for listening so far. I appreciate. that you stayed to the end.
我觉得这种心态——“酷，这会很艰难，但我会充分利用它，我要重塑自我”——当困难真正降临时，会让你对未来抱有更多的积极性和乐观。非常感谢大家的收听。如果你刚刚搬家，或者正在考虑搬家，甚至距离搬家还有六个月，我为你感到非常兴奋，一切都会好起来的，这会很棒，情况会越来越好。如果你坚持听到了这一集的最后，欢迎并非常感谢你一直以来的收听。我很感激你能坚持到最后。
Leave a comment down below. If you've just moved to a new city, where are you living? If you are about to move to a new city, where are you going? If you have a dream city that you want to move to, where is it? And if you've just moved to Sydney by any chance, here is something for your bucket list. If the weather is nice this weekend, go to Redleaf Bay and then get a tasty pastry from breaker blue. That is a freebie tip for people who've maybe just moved to Sydney.
在下方留言告诉我们吧。如果你刚刚搬到一个新城市，你住在哪里？如果你正准备搬到一个新城市，你要去哪里？如果你有一个梦想中想搬去的城市，那是哪里？如果你碰巧刚搬到悉尼，这里有一个可以加入你愿望清单的建议：如果这周末天气不错，去一趟红叶湾，然后在布雷克蓝买一块美味的糕点。这是专门送给刚搬到悉尼的朋友的免费小建议。
That's something I would have on my bucket. list. So enjoy. Good luck. Make sure you're following us on Instagram. Make sure you are subscribed slash following wherever you are listening right now and that's Apple, Spotify, the IHeart Radio app so that you know when we release new episodes and you can stay in touch. Good luck on your new adventure. I sent some amazing friends and some amazing memories in your near future. I just have a good feeling about it. I can sense it for you. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Thank you for listening. And we will talk very, very soon.
这是我会放在愿望清单上的内容。所以，尽情享受吧，祝你好运。请确保在Instagram上关注我们，无论你现在在哪里收听（不管是苹果播客、Spotify还是iHeartRadio应用），都请记得订阅和关注，这样你就不会错过我们发布的新节目，也能与我们保持联系。祝你的新冒险一切顺利。预祝你在不久的将来能结交到棒极了的朋友，拥有美好的回忆。我有一种很好的预感，我能为你感受到这一切。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。感谢收听，我们很快就会再聊。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难成长》。这个节目聚焦黑人群体的经历，进行那些在别处绝对无法安全展开的坦诚对话。你将与一位深谙此道的专业持证人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？它向世界释放出信号：你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你拥有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长》。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在奇异的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学原理。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. On The Look Back at it podcast.
当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个恶劣的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他一定会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们：相信我，宝贝》，在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
从1979年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。1984对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利希。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。这是一个iHeart播客，真人制作，品质保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。